Laci: It's been a week of cuteness, Trace
absolute cuteness.
Are you ready for this?
Trace: I think I'm ready, but can we add just
a bit of awesome.
Laci: Yeah, cuteness and awesome.
Trace: Awesome.
Laci: Hi folks, I'm Laci.
Trace: And I'm Trace, and this is Buttercup.
He lives at the Feathered Angels Waterfall
Sanctuary, and Buttercup was born with his
left foot turned backwards.
And specialists tried to fix it, but it never
really worked right.
Laci: Yea and so now, we have this amazing
thing called technology and 3D printers.
And Buttercup has a foot.
So at first he puts this on and he's like,
not really sure how he feels about it, but
then he's going at it.
He's just so adorable.
It's really really precious what 3D printing
can do for a duck's life.
Trace: It looks pretty good too.
It's bright red.
He's got like a sweet little racer foot there.
And he can move with that thing.
Laci: It's a little bit of a weird hobble
but super adorable.
Trace: I wonder what this means for like prosthetics
for the future for us too.
They've got casts that you could 3D print
now.
And we've got all sorts of cool hands maybe.
Laci: Yeah I feel like I hear some new 3D
printed thing, that's really awesome, everyday.
So what about elephants?
Elephants are cute, right?
And this one is seeing the ocean for the very
first time.
Trace: That's so great!
He looks so happy.
How does he look that happy.
This is an Asian Elephant.
And you can tell by his little ears.
And he's playing in the water near Phuket,
Thailand.
And you know, that's actually not far off
from what I did the first time I saw the ocean.
Laci: Right, and you were probably like, what?
20?
So I'm watching this and I can't help thinking
about how other animals may be experiencing
emotion.
I mean he really does look so happy.
Do animals feel hapiness?
Trace: I don't know.
It sorta seem like they do.
But I don't know if that's us personofying
happiness upon them.
Like, this dog looks happy.
It must feel happy.
But we have done some things on Discoverynews.com
about like, not to bring us down a little
bit, but chimps and they actually grieve for
their dead fellows, if you will.
So I'm sure that there's some rudimentary
animal emotion.
Laci: I mean look at it.
It's so happy.
It's like dunking in the water.
Trace: You know what, it's happy.
I'm gonna say it's happy.
Laci: The answer is yes, animals feel emotion.
Trace: And finally just so we can compose
ourselves before we go back out into the world
from all that cuteness, an awesome shark.
Laci: Yes, this video was just released showing
the thresher shark.
It's totally crazy.
The shark swims up to a school of fish, snaps
its extra long tail, and creates a shockwave
which paralyzes the fish, so it can eat it.
Trace: Aw that is so cool.
It reminds me a little bit of the pistol shrimp,
which does that with a claw with like a loud
noise and whatever.
Laci: It's also paralyzing.
Trace: Yeah, but this is the first time we've
seen this kind of behavior in sharks right?
Cause before, it was like
we've seen it in dolphins.
We've seen it in like, killer whales, but
never in a shark.
So maybe they're actually more intelligent
than we give them credit for.
Laci: Maybe there is something going on up
there.
I mean, it's pretty smart off the bat, cause
they're conserving a lot of energy while they're
hunting this way.
Trace: Sharks are so cool man.
Laci: Go sharks.
We're gonna be talking a lot about sharks,
actually.
August 4th is Shark Week!
So make sure you stay tuned.
We're gonna be doing so much shark stuff.
So that's it for this round guys.
We're always on the lookout for more awesome
videos.
So if you find any, you should totally share
them with us on Facebook, or Google+, or the
Tweet machine.
Trace: For sure.
And as always, keep tuning to Dnews twice
a day, everyday.
See you later everybody.
Laci: Bye bye!